- [James] Right. In a lot of
the content marketing
I think the key is
establishing that trust
so you can build communities.
So the community goes from
whatever they're at before to
"Oh no, here's the guy
I can actually trust."
And that involves a
certain type of sincerity as
opposed to here are the
top 10 things you need
to know about wine.
You kinda have to start off with
here's what I didn't
know about wine
now here's what I'm learning.
So how do you
break into sincerity
'cause I think that is the real
challenge for a lot
of content marketers?
They're still marketing
even through their content.
- I think that's right and
I think you've got it pegged.
I think the North Star
has to be truth.
It's quite simple.
- [James] How do you
know it for your,
let's say someone starts out,
they might not
have all the knowledge
but they don't know.
How do they know
they're being sincere?
Where's the line?
- Oh, I think they know.
- [James] I don't think there's
a technique for sincerity but--
- I don't think, you know,
look, if you do not know
what the truth or not the
truth is within your own body
of your own self, well then
there's nothing I can do
or you can do to help anybody.
I would say 99% of the
people know the truth.
When you come out the gate
and you're 23 years old
and you want to be a life coach
you know that you
haven't lived life yet.
It's not super complicated.
When you want to teach
people how to make money
at 23 because
somebody who's 53
told you this is the quick
way to make money
but you know that
you've never made money
you know that to be true.